all the pressure is here feel this that
is imagine I just make the worst video
of it yeah
whatever we upload I'm fully leaning on
him so if the video is god tier it's
because of him if the video is the worst
it's awesome because
this time last year in Cape Town a good
friend of mine Casey neistat introduced
me to Jimmy or better known as Mr Beast
then we hiked a mountain which was super
tough
let's go
this is hard
anyways later that day I got the
opportunity to show him some of my
filmmaking work but then didn't hear
from him for about a year
then one night while in NYC he called me
hello
yeah dude before we get into that
life-changing call from Mr Beast I just
wanted to let you know that this video
was powered by anchor
if you didn't get my stupid dad joke
that might be a foreshadow to some very
life-changing news as well anchor is a
company that design and makes super fast
charging cables adapters with all kinds
of things but most importantly
the best power banks on the planet so
good that recently I was just in
Antarctica with Mr Beast and the boys
that's right Antarctica which would have
seen in my last video If you haven't go
and watched that but besides the point
we were without electricity for more
than 50 hours and I've been using anchor
to keep me fully charged the entire time
I've been here like it's dropped in the
snow a bunch of times and oh [ __ ] all
the products just they're so robust back
to the video hold up yeah dude and then
you haven't really catch up since uh
South Africa trip uh that was a while
ago I feel like honestly like the Plant
City videos recently I've been lacking
and I'm just drowning and uh I am really
really excited to see what the [ __ ]
happens if we let you just take the
leads out of video so it's like this
really excites me and if it does really
well it's something we can like apply to
Future ones [ __ ] yeah feel free to come
down if you want to show you around the
facilities you can check out the charity
and everything like that
okay basically what just happened is
Jimmy offered me the opportunity to come
on board and direct the film for the
abuse philanthropy Channel and if I
could imagine the most fulfilling job
for me as a film director it would be to
create films with real meaning films
that create actual change so there's a
lot riding on this for me I immediately
packed my camera bag which obviously
contained all my anchor gear because
when I'm missioning around I'm always on
planes I'm always on the hustle and I
constantly need to stay charged so a day
later I arrived in this random town in
the middle of nowhere called Greenville
to find out more about Mr Beast but more
importantly he's philanthropy what is
Beast philanthropy so like with
beastland they've we started the channel
we used the money from the channel to
feed people you know we kind of forget
the numbers on YouTube are real people
and so you know if we can use that to
help ease human suffering and on top of
that when we make the videos a large
part of my audience is younger so it
inspires them to do that when they're
the person they look up to you know kind
of makes doing good cool to them then it
inspires them to go do good like parents
will be like my 14 year old kid wants to
volunteer he watches your beastfly 3
Channel and like now he volunteers every
Saturday and younger sometimes donating
their tooth fairy money it's about
inspiring the the younger generation to
do good amazing
also I don't know where we found this
guy
imagine I just make the worst videos
whatever we upload on Peaceful Anthony
I'm fully leaning on him so if the video
is god tier it's like you're like this
is the best peaceful anthropy video it's
because of him if the video is the worst
baseball interview you're like this is
unwatchable it's awesome
then I went to go and check out their
facility
[Applause]
food to the community every month this
food bank is only a fraction of the
global change making projects they do
like building walls in Africa cleaning
the oceans and many more and while I was
there I actually got the chance to
Shadow on one of their shoots see how
they are currently making their videos
thank you
this is Darren executive chief of
everything Beast philanthropy right most
days I pretend to be what do you guys do
video professional camera pointers we're
running six cameras right now so six
cameras Oh my gosh
I then flew back to Cape Town to start
working on our first collaboration and
hopefully the start of many more on the
plane I wrote a bunch of things that I
believe could improve their videos
firstly Cadence Cadence is the delivery
it's the conversation with the audience
and what the objective of the channel is
to create a long-term conversation
between the viewers and the work the
philanthropy the goodness that the
channel is doing currently the Cadence
leans too far into the entertainment
realm which I totally get which is
Jimmy's main Channel however if we just
had to alter the Cadence slightly I feel
that the delivery will be more sincere
channels like Beast philanthropy are
Paving the way to make it easier for
individuals to jump on board and create
change then
music this is one of my favorite parts
of the filmmaking process currently the
music and the Beast philanthropy videos
are it's predictable it's as if the
music is used in a way in which to tell
the audience how to feel so we are going
to be creating the soundtrack for this
piece the soundtrack from scratch
otherwise known as scoring a piece of
music and lastly
way too many cameras
this one's easy to understand there's
far too many cameras all pointing in the
same direction I like to go with one
camera two cameras Max this also helps
slim down the editing process it's
easier to control it's easier to
understand what you're shooting
watching this edit back ah it seems like
I'm sitting on some high horse and
throwing shade this is not the intent
this is this is just my opinion the way
that I make videos it's my style I had
absolutely no idea if this is gonna work
so you're gonna have to wait till the
end of this video to see if Jimmy
actually liked this video in the first
place oh yeah I realized that I also
didn't even contextualize the brief I
didn't contextualize the project that I
was commissioned to create and short
because I don't want to give too much
away the film has just gone live on the
Beast philanthropy Channel but together
we are rebuilding 12 new houses for an
orphanage in a rural Township in Cape
Town called kayanicha for kids in
desperate need of new homes
I really tried my hardest to direct
something powerful
okay that's it the edit's done I'm just
about to head back to Greenville North
Carolina to present the edit to Jimmy
and to Darren yes I know I could just
send it over we transfer a bit for
dramatic purposes and because I have to
go back to America anyway I'm going to
present it to them in person
Jimmy and Darren both didn't want me to
watch them watching the film I made for
them which I totally get but then I got
this message from Jimmy
and then Darren sent me this that is
absolutely incredible I can see why
Jimmy loves a time actually you you
nailed it you did an absolutely perfect
job okay so after this response what's
next Jimmy and Darren have offered me
the position as
CCO which is the
Chief creative officer I hate titles but
basically this means that I'll be making
all their films for Beast philanthropy
which means moving to North Carolina
turning down all my other phone
directing work days in a third point so
I don't know why I'm doing that but that
was a really really easy decision to
make I literally cannot wait for this
year ahead I feel like all my fails on
YouTube all my wins on YouTube all my
hard work all the late nights all the
frustration the moments where I'm like
this is actually working is this worth
it you know am I going crazy should I
try something else it's all reached a
point where it now makes sense as well
as my team here at Joe my South African
team they'll be very involved in the
creation of all of these projects I am
beyond grateful just
if I was an actor I'd queue tears yeah
tears of joy I will also still be
regularly uploading videos to my YouTube
channel a look behind the scenes of The
Genius of Mr Beast what goes into these
videos how they're made so yeah this is
definitely not the end of this Channel
at all also thank you so much to the
brands that have helped me along the way
that have kept me going like the sponsor
of this video yeah I just wanted to tell
you something that's really exciting
about
please watch this last section it really
helps with the retention of the videos
and YouTube likes that a new product a
super Super Rad new product the Anka 733
power bank from the Gan Prime lineup
it's a high power capacity fast charger
Ultra Compact and portable and with and
what's super cool is that it can charge
multiple high-powered devices like
tablets
laptops iPhones at the same time so all
you need is just this thing and then you
can charge all of this stuff so yeah
Power A Greener World with less E-Waste
with multi-port design meaning you need
less charges and other than that don't
forget you're awesome brew and I can't
wait for this year ahead with you
fear
[Music]